we begin this morning with president
biden who is spending his second day in
saudi arabia for a high-stakes meeting
with the leaders of oil-producing arab
states among the issues they will
discuss global energy security high oil
prices and middle east peace the summit
comes on the heels of the president's
friday interaction with controversial
saudi leader muhammad bin salman ed
o'keefe is traveling with the president
he is in the city of jeddah the red sea
joins us now ed good morning
dana good morning great to be with you
the president so far this morning has
held meetings with the leaders of iraq
egypt and other countries as he prepares
to lay out his broader visions for the
middle east somewhere he's eager to
continue exerting influence even if it
means taking criticism for something
that transpired last night
it was the fist bump seen round the
world giving the media savvy saudi crown
prince mohammed bin salman a viral
moment he long sought president biden
was reluctant to hold the meeting given
that he'd denounced the prince after u.s
intelligence confirmed mbs had ordered
the murder of one of his most prominent
critics washington post contributing
columnist jamal khashoggi on friday the
president said he raised the killing at
the start of his meeting with the prince
where the fist bumping continued with
other top u.s officials
i raised it at the top of the meeting
making it clear what i thought of it at
the time
and what i think of it now and it was
exactly i was straightforward and direct
in discussing it i made my view crystal
clear mr biden was asked how mbs
responded he basically said that he
he was not personally responsible for it
i indicated i thought he was there was a
clear difference of opinion confirmed by
saudi minister of state for foreign
affairs adele al-jabir who was in the
meeting the crown prince himself did not
take blame for the murder the charges
that the crown prince knew about it or
much less ordered it are ridiculous
khashoggi's fiancee tweeted a
photoshopped image of what he might have
thought of the meeting writing the blood
of mbs's next victim is on your hands
i'm sorry she feels that way the post's
publisher denounced the shameful scene
is giving mbs the unwarranted redemption
he's been desperately seeking the
president is expected to leave saudi
arabia today without explicit assurance
as the saudis will boost oil production
to ease gas prices but opec leaders are
set to discuss doing so next month
i suspect you won't see that for another
couple weeks al-jabir said the problem
for the u.s isn't global oil supply but
its own lack of refining capacity high
gasoline prices are really a function of
many many things one is the fact that
america has a shortage of refining
capacity no refinery has been built in
decades and so even if you bring more
oil to the market if it cannot be
refined into gasoline it will not lead
to a drop of prices at the pump
and just a few moments ago the president
was seen again alongside mbs at the
beginning of a regional conference of
arab nations he flies home in a few
hours after four intensive days he
agreed with israel that they're going to
work together to stop iran from
developing a nuclear weapon gave out
more aid to the palestinians but
conceded that the israelis and
palestinians aren't going to be able to
hold peace talks of any real substance
for quite some time here in saudi arabia
he was able to stick it to the crown
prince but he leaves with no assurance
from the saudis that they'll help drive
down the price of gasoline an issue
that's likely to dock him in the months
leading up to the midterm elections
adriana
indeed ed thank you